What I want to do in
this video is think about
how far can I see from
the window of a plane
when a plane is at
its cruising altitude.
And just to give us some
numbers to work with,
let's just assume that the
cruising altitude that we
are working with, the altitude
of the plane, is 10 kilometers.
And the number for the radius
of the earth-- and so this
will be important
for figuring out
how far I can see
from the plane.
Let me do this is
a different color.
The earth's radius-- I'll do
it in green-- in kilometers
is 6,371 kilometers.
And it's actually not
constant throughout the earth,
but we're going to assume that
for the sake of this problem
that Earth is a perfect sphere.
It actually is not
one, but we will
assume that it's
a perfect sphere.
And its radius is
roughly 6,371 kilometers.
So given this
information, can we
figure out how far can we
see on a perfectly clear day
from the window of
a plane cruising
at an altitude of 10 kilometers?
And I encourage you
to pause this video
and try to think
about it on your own.
So I assume you've
given a go at it.
So let's draw Earth.
And this by no stretch
of the imaginations
will be a scale drawing either
of Earth or of the plane
flying above the
surface of Earth.
So let's say that this
right over here is Earth.
I would want to draw it as a
perfect sphere, but I have not.
But you understand
my limitations.
Now let's see what we could do.
So the plane is traveling at
an altitude of 10 kilometers.
So let's say that this is
the plane right over here.
And this distance, once
again, by no stretch
of the imagination drawn
to scale, is 10 kilometers.
And then if we were
to keep going down
to the center of the
earth, that would
be another 6,371 kilometers.
And when you think about
how far you could see,
your line of sight is
really forming a tangent
with some point on the
surface of the earth.
So this is me in my plane.
And let's say I'm looking
at that direction.
How far could I see?
Well, I'm going to be
hitting the surface
of the earth at some point.
And that line of
sight is essentially
going to be tangent
to the surface.
So let me see if I can draw
it a little bit cleaner.
So let's see, it's going to
be tangent to the surface.
So it's going to look
something like that.
And so this is the
furthest point I could see,
the point at which
my line of sight
is just tangent to the
surface of the earth.
Well, how far is that
point of the surface
going to be from the
center of the earth?
Well, we're assuming that
Earth is a perfect sphere.
So that's also going
to be 6,371 kilometers.
And the other thing we
know is that a tangent line
is going to be
perpendicular to a radius.
So this right over here is
going to be a right angle.
And all sorts of bells should
be ringing in your brain
at this point
because we have just
constructed a right triangle.
And what we want to figure
out, how far we can see-- well,
that's this unknown side
of this right triangle,
the side that I
have marked in x.
So we can just use the
Pythagorean theorem.
We know that the square of
this side, so x squared,
plus the square of this
other non-hypotenuse side,
so 6,371 squared, is going
to be equal to the square
of the hypotenuse.
So what is the length
of the hypotenuse?
Well, the hypotenuse is 6,371
kilometers plus this extra 10
kilometers of altitude squared.
And so we get x squared
plus 6,371 squared
is equal to-- what
is this going to be?
This is going to be this whole
distance right over here.
The whole distance is just
going to be 6,381 kilometers,
and we're going to square that.
So x squared-- we just subtract
6,371 squared from both sides.
We get x squared
is equal to 6,381
squared minus 6,371 squared.
Or we could say that x is
equal to the square root of all
of this business.
And I could just
copy and paste that.
So copy, and paste.
Let's throw that right in there.
Actually, my radical
is not big enough.
So let me make my radical
a little bit bigger.
And then we can use a calculator
to actually compute this.
So let me get my calculator out.
And this is exciting
because now we can finally
know on a perfectly clear
day how far we can see out
of a plane.
So it's going to be the
square root of 6,381 squared
minus 6,371 squared, which
is going to be-- we deserve
a drum roll-- roughly
357 kilometers,
if we round to the
nearest kilometer.
So x is approximately
equal to 357 kilometers
in any direction.
So you could see 357
kilometers in that direction.
You could see 357 kilometers
in that direction.
So let's say you're
looking at a map of the US,
and your plane is
flying across it.
And this is kind of neat.
And once again, this is by
no means drawn to scale,
but let's say that this right
over here is North America.
That's the Yucatan Peninsula.
That's Louisiana.
I'll draw Lake Pontchartrain
right over there.
And then see, that's Florida.
And then that's the
rest of North America.
That's California,
just like that.
That's Vancouver.
I could keep going--
Alaska, so on and so forth.
So if you're flying
in your plane,
and your plane is right here,
if we assume the numbers we just
assumed, in any direction,
you can see 357 kilometers.
So 357 kilometers would
be about that far.
So you could see that
far in every direction.
So it's kind of like seeing
an entire state-- or actually
multiple states, depending
on what state you're
thinking about-- of the
US from your window,
if you could look
in every direction.
Obviously, if
you're only sitting
on one side of the
plane, you could only
look out of one window.
But maybe you could go switch
to the other side of the plane
and see the other side, as well.
But you're actually
seeing a substantive area
when you look out of the window
from 10 kilometers, which
is roughly about
32,000 feet in the air.